alle
oui bien sûr allez-y entrez c'est un
très bel endroit montrez-moi la salle de
bain elle a besoin d'être
nettoyée je veux que vous nettoyez
derrière les
toilettes est-ce que c'est sale oui
quand vous pensez à vous qu'est-ce que
vous voyez quelque chose du genre déchet
oh ou vous n'êtes rien du
[Musique]
tout j'ai beaucoup aimé ce scénario moi
aussi ça va être tellement bizarre que
ça ne fasse plus partie de ma routine
tout ça qu'est-ce que tu veux
[Musique]
dire tu sais ce poste ton nouveau rôle
dans l'entreprise PDG
oui c'est probablement pas une bonne
idée de continuer à faire
ça
je dis simplement que ton nouveau
travail tu serais pas capable de le
faire sans ce que je t'ai appris
qu'est-ce que tu veux la moitié du
salaire de la première année pour le
PO domin
denanchement quand tu dis comme ça ça
l'air
étrange il y a une camé cach dans cette
suite d' j'ai pas envie de jouer
je as FM no séances en
cachette
où est cette caméra tuas qu'à la
chercher si tu veux la trouver tu es une
psychopathe si je le voulais je pourrais
me débarrasser de toi regardetoi tu as
adoré ça vous êtes
excité enlève ton
pantalon tu n'as plus le pouvoir c'est
mon tour qu'est-ce qu' prend
qu'est-ce que tu veux j'ai débloqué
quelque chose toi non sanctuaire
sanctuaire le safe World sanctuaire
est-ce que je peux savoir pourquoi tu
fais ça ou c'est juste un jeu pour toi
oui regardez-moi ne me regardez pas
désolé